hi well we're moving on
now to uh film number four and it's
going to be about the Joe and I'm going
to just go back a moment and I suggested
that you do five of each of the Joe
subur and you're aiming for and of
course it'll be repetition you need a
small gap of breathing after the five
repetitions of if you're doing the the
first subur or the 20th subur whatever
subur you've chosen to do the repetition
is five small pause small breather in
between you can either bring your hand
down close your eyes if you want to do
something
mechanically breathe in through the
nose out through the mouth just to clear
your mind and clear
yourself 30 minutes
to a minute breather if you need more
please take
more there's a lot more obviously
there's seven Ken
saures and there's the hairi with the
Ken there's also the hairi with the
Joe but it's going to take you a lot
longer to get three of the Joe feeling
the same because you got 20 of them to
get through so this would should take a
long time might take years could take
months depending on your level depending
on your depth of understanding depending
on how deep you want to
go but the same as with the can if
you're going to do
HAPO with the uh Joe I suggest you do
the same thing by striking it using the
Striking method as if it's a Ken once
you've done that with a
Joe can you make that Joe feel like a
Ken yes it's round it's longer it will
feel different than the Ken but your aim
now is to make the Ken or Joe feel part
of you so when you're using it you're
trying to feel the balance of you within
that Ken within that Joe rather than it
be becoming a distinguished separation
of Ken or Joe
um once you've done the first
subur you can do the second subari with
the Joe the third subury the fourth
subari the fifth subari the sixth subari
the seventh C subur so this is then your
program now at this stage with the Joe
you're trying to see if you can
replicate the C feeling but with the
using the
Joe you'll find this very challenging I
think so again you're looking for five
repetitions you're trying to hit hit a
target of three feeling the
same out of the out of each five
segments you take that pause of breath
before you do the next five pause a
breath before you do the next five and
depending on the amount of time that you
can spare to give it each time and if
you can do it daily then it's
great um your aim is to get three of
those feeling the same whether it now be
with Ken or Joe but don't try with the
Joe and then say I think I've got it and
then take your Ken and do it with the
Ken and try to see if it feels the same
um to me that's um rather looking at it
desperately and the body knows far more
than perhaps
you're you're not going to like this
vanity needs uh for it to be correct but
you'll know because it'll be smooth and
it will just feel really Pleasant to to
do
it okay so with so the first um
seven Joe with with the
doing it with the Joe but they're the
movements of the seven
caner this is your next stage of
advancement okay if you're going to do
um be strict with yourself then the
following time the next night or
whatever but not the same day uh you can
perhaps try it with the Ken and just see
if that reminds you of when you were
doing it with a Joe if not you need more
work the the more you're in our Rush the
longer it will take you to get the more
you're prepared to study and search for
Oneness uh and completeness of it coming
together the better your iido will be
the better you will become as a martial
artist thank you for your time and uh I
hope you're progressing now
lastly uh with this IDI program that you
can be doing at home and by now you
should find that when you go to the club
or practice with a partner you should
find that your iido is becoming stronger
more solid and your Technique is getting
better even though you've done nothing
to improve the techniques apart from
working at home or with on your chemist
thank you for progressing with me this
far